[Musique]
nous assistons à une révolution
numérique qui aboutit à numériser
l'ensemble des secteurs de la société ce
matin on en parlait de façon générique
pour l'ensemble des collectivités
locales est donc une nécessité absolue
afin d'accompagner en fait la gestion du
numérique avec une vigilance accrue sur
la cyber menaces
[Musique]
la plateforme a pour objectif de fédérer
les données qui sont les données et les
sous systèmes qui sont déjà disposés
dans les villes ça peut être une caméra
de vidéo protection
mais ça peut aussi être un détecteur de
bruit c'est ensemble là va permettre de
dire il ya un bruit anormal à un moment
donné dans la journée est-ce que c'est
pas un chantier pirate est ce que ce
n'est pas une fête où est ce que ce
n'est pas un incident qui s'est produit
[Musique]
ah ah